[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday October 10th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
last week President Biden signs an
executive order that would give
Europeans a new right to challenge U.S
government surveillance practices
against them the move is a key step in
enacting a data privacy deal between the
U.S and the EU one that has taken years
to reach up part of the issue is whether
companies can store the data of
Europeans on U.S soil which is key for
U.S tech Giants because if they can't
then some of those companies say they'll
have to pull out of Europe joining us to
explain what this latest step means for
the future of transatlantic data privacy
is our European Tech reporter Sam
schechner Hi Sam thanks for joining me
hi thanks for having me Sam can you
start off with a bit of background I
mean what led to this move well in a way
this goes back a couple of decades you
know to the end of the 1990s the EU
started implementing privacy rules and
they were saying that information about
people in Europe
can't be sent to countries where it's
not properly protected and they struck a
deal with the US which they called Safe
Harbor which said okay it's okay to send
to the U.S if companies agree to a
certain number of EU privacy rules
after the revelations by former NSA
contractor Edward Snowden more than a
decade later
people in Europe were pretty upset about
the allegations that their data hosted
by American tech companies could have
been accessed by the NSA or other
intelligence services and a top EU Court
actually struck down that Safe Harbor
agreement and we've been seeing this
kind of back and forth between where to
put the line between
privacy and commerce going back all this
time and so most recently a new
agreement was struck down and companies
have been kind of operating in limbo are
they allowed to send data about people
living in Europe like me to servers in
the US so what does this executive order
mean for the data of people living in
the EU well this executive order
basically the restriction on sending
data is a European restriction Europe
says you can't send data outside of the
EU unless it's safe to do so and they
pre-authorize places that are safe so
Europe's ask was make it safe in
compliance with this court order that
struck down the prior agreement this is
the U.S executive order that that seeks
to do that based on negotiations with
the European commission the reason that
this agreement that allowed the data to
be sent was struck down was that an EU
Court said that Europeans didn't have
really actionable rights to do anything
about the surveillance if they were
thought they were being improperly
surveilled and that there needed to be
more legal redress and so what this new
agreement includes is on one hand new
guidelines and guard rails against what
the EU and U.S would call
disproportionate surveillance
surveillance that might say Seek to
repress dissent and then also this
redress that the EU Court had asked for
and it creates a new entity called the
data protection review court that could
give a secondary review to cases if
Europeans complain in the EU their
complaints can be sent to this court for
a kind of adjudication eventually so
what happens now that this executive
order has been signed well in the EU the
executive arm called the European
commission is going to review the
executive order and see if it matches
what they've been asking for
both the U.S and the commission really
want to make sure that this survives
what will be an inevitable Court review
and it's going to go back to the same
court that struck down the prior
agreement so both the European
commission and the U.S want to make sure
this deal survives a court review and
that's why they negotiated it this way
you know an EU official on Friday said
that they were confident that they could
defend this new data agreement against
legal challenges which suggests that
they're likely to give the executive
order that rubber stamp approval called
adequacy which will allow companies to
send their data more freely from the EU
to the US
all right what does this mean though for
tech companies and particularly for some
of the biggest U.S tech companies in
essence this helps remove some of the
uncertainty that they're facing about
the future of these data transfers after
the last court decision there have been
some cases moving through with EU
privacy Regulators that could have had a
really severe impact on for instance
meta there's a pending order
that meta should stop both Facebook and
Instagram from sending any data about
Europeans to the US that's still going
to take a few months to come through and
it may in fact come through before this
deal is finalized meta has said that if
that order were made effective that they
might have to stop offering some of
their services in Europe so it's a
significant operational challenge for a
company like that
there's a lot of other companies that
use American cloud services and if this
kind of data transfer were ruled illegal
would have to perhaps start storing more
data in Europe and so it is a
significant relief for a lot of
companies to see that this deal is
coming to fruition and it seems more
likely to be finally approved okay we'll
have to leave it there that's our
European Tech reporter Sam schechner
thanks for joining us Sam always a
pleasure
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com and if you
like our show please rate and review it
you can do that wherever you get your
podcasts I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal
thanks for listening
thank you
foreign